kim yo-jong issued a statement saying
the new u.s administration should quote
refrain from causing a stink if it wants
to sleep in peace
for the coming four years it's the first
time pyongyang has addressed the biden
administration
since last year's presidential election
after visiting japan
top u.s officials are due to arrive in
seoul on wednesday
for more on this uh journalist jen kwon
joins us now from seoul
a warning from pyongyang to washington
what should we make of this statement
most of the statement says it's
unhappiness about the joint military
drills with the u.s and south korea
however this is just an excuse to show
how they're disappointed and what they
want from
the region actually because the military
jails already have started off
and it's been uh there's only two days
left with the military drills
and rather the envoys usm voice visit to
this
region has kicked off um
secretary of state austin and
secretary of defense secretary of state
blinken and secretary of defense
austin would arrive to south korea
tomorrow and this gives
enough space for the two alliance to
talk about how to deal with north korea
if we're looking at this statement is it
significant that it's coming from kim
jong-un's sister
instead of directly from the north
korean leader
kim jong-un has been playing this bad
good cop black hop role
so kim jong-un is the good cop always
the benevolent leader
who reaches out to the foreign country
to
um to build peace in the uh
in the korean peninsula however his
sister
the closest to him actually tells what
he really thinks of a negative thing
this is not the first time that kim
jong-un shows anger towards south korea
last year she was the one who stated
that north korea would
blast and inter korea communication
building which has shocked the south
koreans
um they sent out a statement and later
on that day
they blew up the the whole building that
was uh
sort of like a commemoration of
the two korea starting dialogue and
trying to build peace
well u.s defense secretary lloyd also
excuse me when i interrupt you there
lloyd olson and secretary of state
anthony blinken are you to arrive in
seoul on wednesday as we've heard
what can we expect out of this visit
so there will be a two plus two uh
meeting
so the foreign ministry and the defense
minister uh
ministry would meet from south korea and
then the u.s they would discuss on
reinvigorating the alliance
so the talks would be about the alliance
between us and korea reaffirming
we there have been discussions on the
defense the cost which has finally got
um accounts to an agreement after
nearly two nearly two years but also
um there will be talks on how to deal
with north korea especially as kim
jong-un sends out a statement
while considering the growing powers
with china
journalist jan kwon in seoul thank you
very much
you